you know what i was uh for whatever
reason i went down this weird rabbit
hole couldn't sleep the other night
you know what the oldest religion in the
world is uh hold on
the oldest religion in the world may
very well be
hinduism yeah i knew you would
hinduism the oldest you punished us
oldest
also has the thousand years yeah for
some reason i figured it'd be
and i didn't in i you know when it comes
to religion i'm a [ __ ] but
uh islamic's the newest yes
islam because i thought islam would be
the oldest because of the middle east
and like islam is islam came after there
was judaism
then there was the new testament and
then islam came so islam actually looks
at the old testament which is
fascinating because how the muslims and
the jews have
trouble yes islam believes that the old
testament is all true
yes it doesn't say that the old
testament the old testament is the truth
and then the islam is kind of a rebuttal
to the new testament because jesus said
he was god
and that they believed jesus was a
prophet but when you say jesus
is god it's considered heretical it's
considered against god
and then i started looking at hinduism
because the oldest religion and when you
look at it like
that makes sense like you really like
they believe in you know like
it just when you read about hinduism
like i can definitely see
reincarnation and stuff and like you
know there's more than one god and
there's this for this reason and
you're being a good person the problem
with having a polytheistic religion like
that we have a lot more gods yeah and
the difference between that and say
having a mono
like christianism so one god so when you
have one god everybody's brothers and
sisters
everybody's equal because we're all in
the same strategy right
if you have a lot of gods what what
happens in hinduism is you get
a caste system but you get people that
are close to the brahmanas
correct you know but then then that's
where buddhism comes from right because
they don't have a caste system
buddhism does not have a caste system
but buddhism does have the idea that you
have
an uh you have rebirths yeah it's nice
you're rebir
you're reborn into a lucky body yes a
higher birth
and a lower birth so so that that's what
they'll tell you that was and and the
same thing in in
in remember so the boo so the buddha was
initially essentially you could probably
say a hindu he was indian he was an
indian prince you'd have to be right
yeah he's an indian prince
so he then went on to kind of create his
own idea of
being one with god when you're when you
meditate to say you reach enlightenment
which means you're
one with god to say that you're one with
god as a christian
is heretical you know they'll get burned
the biggest religion
on on the planet you know has the most
followers
um it might be islam but but it might be
i thought it was islam too it might be
christianity christianity in 2050 you
know who's
going to be by far the biggest oh
christianity
but did you know that uh amongst males
uh i think it's i think it's 30 and
under
uh over 50 percent don't believe in a
god
atheist i think the more you see that
poll
i think the more with like online and
people having data and you know and
people and a lot of you know
i didn't grow up that religious so i'm
not that religious and that my kid's not
probably not going to grow up
so the more we get away from the old
days of going to church every sunday
i think you get more of that yeah well
the the the um
i'm not saying it's the right thing i'm
just saying they say the more educated
you are the less religious you become
but i don't think that the two are
diametrically opposed i think you can be
very religious and you can also be very
educated
isaac newton the father of physics knew
more about science than anybody
and math and was a genius he was very
religious
so yeah i guess if you're that smart and
you believe in
there's room for science it's hard to
believe in well there's room for science
and myth and the power of myth
the truth of myth the idea that doing
the right thing
is better than doing the wrong thing and
and that that the
path to least resistance is walking a
righteous path
right so that would be the idea because
if you believe in like neurons and this
stuff create it start it there and then
they go well who created their neurons
it's like oh
age old debate yeah right age old debate
it's interesting
and when i was looking at religion i
thought i thought islam would be by far
the biggest because
so many muslims you know in the middle
east and china and
india all this you know i figured all of
christianity
is so big all of south america christian
most of the united states christians
so big europe is a christian nation a
christian continent pretty much yeah all
of all of russia all of you know
and huge christian populations in like
korea
in probably even china did you guys grow
up going to church cat
uh no i was raised buddhist that's cool
are you still buddhist yeah but i'm not
very religious
i'll go to the temple once in a while
when i read up on buddha especially as
i'm older i'm like i
that makes more sense to me than any of
these other religions it just
i i for for me i just makes more sense
to me yeah
did you grab going to church i think for
a little while christian too
but i don't really practice you know
yeah but yeah for a little while but
then we stopped
what about you guys i mean i've been to
church once
twice well my parents just did and my
grandparents kind of were like oh
yeah i went a bunch of times when i was
younger
then when me and my brother got old
enough we're like dude what we
hate this yeah we threw the biggest fit
somebody was like right let's stop going
and then you know i would go to a bible
study when i first moved to l.a
twice a week for like a year and a year
and a half tim tebow
yeah you you know there is a lot of
value in it
i i people think there's no value no no
there's there's in any religion whatever
you are there's good value and there's
good lessons there's good takeaways
if you take it you know word for word
you and i think you've
over analyzed you're like what are you
talking about man but the
overall messages and in anything you
believe are good you take good from it
i learn stuff from it i don't believe in
it but i there's good messages and
you know it makes you anal well there's
a difference in taking it literally and
taking it symbolically yeah
yeah so there we have it yeah i stopped
going when i was
uh talking to someone um part
who's part of the group and like you
know it's important that you convert and
accept jesus in your life i'm like yeah
i hear you man you know and they go
because you know if you don't what do
you mean i go well my my dad my brother
they're you know they're atheists they
don't believe in they go
then they're going to hell yeah i went
oh i'm not coming back
you're using fear yeah well i'm not
coming back that's not true
yeah but then it's true jordan peterson
does a very good job of creating
space for both religion and science and
met
meshing the two that's what his
contribution has been he's amazing
i mean he's he just makes he's very
religious but also very scientifically
interesting and he makes a [ __ ] great
article
and and yuval herrari in his book
sapiens does the same thing i have
sapiens yes
the power the power of story and how
that can make a huge difference
yeah so there we have it ladies and
gentlemen
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue
oh okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do
use some of that boxing you've been
doing